reunidos en Bruselas los ministros de
defensa de la otan se enfrentaron al
espinoso tema del objetivo de gasto
militar para cada país miembro
actualmente es el 2% del pib el
secretario general James staltenberg
afirmó que la necesidad de comprometerse
con el objetivo que actualmente es solo
una sugerencia es más importante que
nunca creo que deberíamos pasar de
considerar el 2% como un techo a
considerar el 2% del pib como un suelo
un mínimo pero la cuestión ha quedado
aplazada hasta la próxima cumbre de la
otan en julio dado que la mayoría de los
países miembros incumplen actualmente el
objetivo de gasto en alrededor de medio
punto porcentual es dudoso que se
convierta en obligatorio dejando a un
lado los objetivos los aliados de La
otan aumentaron el gasto en defensa por
octavo año consecutivo en 2022 los
países aparte de Estados Unidos
añadieron alrededor de 328 mil millones
de euros a sus arcas de guerra desde
2014 en la Cumbre el Secretario de
Defensa estadounidense se mostró
optimista sobre la reciente oleada de
promesas de armamento para Ucrania con
esa capacidad adicional tropas mejor
entrenadas plataformas que pueden rendir
mejor en este entorno creo que tendrán
una oportunidad realmente buena de
marcar una diferencia bastante
significativa en el campo de batalla
actualmente Ucrania está utilizando
proyectiles más rápidos de lo que
occidente puede fabricarlos esto el
temberg afirmó que los miembros de la
otan estaban aumentando la producción de
proyectiles de artillería Pero dijo que
era necesario acelerarla gift también
quiere aviones de combate misiles de
largo alcance a lo que los países de la
otan se muestran reticentes pero no lo